basic traffic metrics such as unique
visitors overall pageviews session
length and interval and traffic sources
can help you establish a good baseline
on how a site or an app is doing but you
want other metrics to help you monitor
the quality of the user experience the
Hart framework can help you define the
UX metrics that are relevant to your
product Hart is an acronym that stands
for five broad categories first is
happiness these metrics are often
captured through surveys and measure
user attitudes they're things like
satisfaction perceived ease of use and
Net Promoter Score engagement is the
second category these metrics monitor
user behavior perhaps frequency
intensity and depth over some period of
time for example Udacity might be
interested in the number of videos
watched per user per day Instagram on
the other hand might measure the number
of photos uploaded per user per week
these types of metrics will really
depend on the types of activities that
your users will do the next category is
adoption you can track the number of new
users who use a product or potential
feature for instance you might track the
number of new accounts created each week
or daily usage of a feature such as
bookmarking in a browser VR is for
retention you learned about retention
already which lets you track active
users from some starting time to some
ending time finally the last category is
tasks success these types of metrics are
related to traditional behavior metrics
such as efficiency time to complete a
task effectiveness which is percent of
completed tasks and error rate now you
don't need to have metrics for all of
these categories instead you should
think about which categories and their
associated metrics will be most
important for the entire product you
also might think about which metrics
would be important for specific features
of a product